eigentlich ist es unmöglich denn diese
elemente gibt es eigentlich gar nicht
trotzdem wird das periodensystem immer
größer es kommen elemente dazu vier
elemente sind erst vor kurzem dazu
gekommen obwohl es sie auf der erde so
eigentlich nicht gibt und das muss man
sich mal vor augen führen sind keine
moleküle die man mit einer chemische
reaktionen erzeugen könnte sondern eben
reine atome grundbausteine weitere
spannende facts zum thema bekommt er
jetzt in klicks um science-fiction
herzlich willkommen und vielen dank auch
wieder für diesen spannenden themen
vorschlag den er mir über die messenger
geschickt habt
erst mal vielen dank an die leute bei
den messenger dort und auf unserem neuen
desktop server geht so viele
themenvorschläge ein absoluter hammer
vielen dank neu dabei im periodensystem
der elemente sind seit gut anderthalb
jahren organisch tennessee nosko wie um
und leoni um ende 2016 war offiziell
klar welche namen diese vier elemente
bekommen sollten
denn sie werden künstlich hergestellt
durch den zusammenprall von atomkernen
und das auch nur in sehr kleinen mengen
in der natur kommen sie nicht vor und
auch in dem künstlichen
herstellungsprozess zerfallen sie sehr
schnell und jetzt mal zu den vier
kandidaten die alle die siebte periode
des systems vervollständigen starten wir
mal mit dem léonie um nhs hat die
ordnungszahl 113 und erinnert euch
vielleicht aus dem chemieunterricht dass
das bedeutet dass es 113 protonen in
seinem atom kern hat entdeckt wurde das
american institute in japan und somit
auch ist es das erste element das in
asien getauft wurde
wie horn ist eine art den namen japans
in landessprache auszusprechen und seine
bedeutung ist fast schon romantisch es
steht für das land der aufgehenden sonne
weiter geht es mit dem element moskwy um
mit der ordnungszahl 115 das von einem
forschungsteam in der nähe von moskau
entdeckt wurde
er ahnt es schon daher also sein name
genauso wie beim element mit der
ordnungszahl 117 tennessee ebenfalls
benannt nach dem ort seiner entdeckung
dem us bundesstaat tennessee dass ein
teil des forschungsteams seinen sitz in
kalifornien hat darüber können die
wissenschaftler und wissenschaftlerinnen
wohl hinwegsehen
schließlich gibt es bereits ein element
mit dem namen kalifornien
wer sich von euch ein bisschen im
bereich chemie auskennt kann sich
vielleicht auch denken an wen der name
des elements 118 organe von og erinnern
soll und zwar an den russischen
kernphysiker juli organisieren der die
theoretischen grundlagen dafür gelegt
hatte dass zahlreiche sehr schwere
elemente überhaupt entdeckt worden waren
der russe ist damit übrigens erst der
zweite mensch weltweit der noch zu
lebzeiten als namensvetter für ein
chemisches element ausgewählt wurde
verantwortlich für die namensgebung ist
der chemiker verband namens
international union of pure and applied
chemistry
you back die die endgültigen namen der
vier super schweren elemente ende 2016
verkündet hatte vorher dürften die
entdecker namensvorschläge machen anfang
2016 hatte die ju pack die elemente
zunächst einmal anerkannt entdeckt
wurden die firmen nämlich übrigens schon
viel früher nämlich zwischen 2002 und
2010 dazu noch ein kleiner fun fact am
rande mehr als 40.000 motorrad fans
hatten sich in einer petition dafür
ausgesprochen eines der elemente nach
dem verstorbenen sänger lemmy kilmister
zu benennen lemmy um wäre dann der name
des neuen elements gewesen die
begründung lemmy war eine naturgewalt
und verkörperte das wesen des heavy
metal
mal sehen vielleicht wird demnächst ein
weiteres element entdeckt dass dann nach
lemmy benannt werden kann wenn ihr kein
video zu diesem thema und zu allen
anderen themen verpassen wollt dann
endet mich bei whatsapp und in anderen
messenger nur dann verpasst er kein
video denn ihr wisst ja die abo box auf
youtube ist ja ein bisschen lückenhaft
über die messenger erfahrt ihr von mir
auch vor allen anderen vom neuesten
video täglich garantiert da bekommen wir
auch den link zum disco server wo ich
seit neuestem fast den ganzen tag rum
menge einfach hier draufklicken klicken
und am besten auch meinen schwesterkanal
klicks um social media abonnieren da
erfahrt ihr das neueste aus der social
media welt aber nicht die genau glocke
vergessen und hier geht es weiter mit
der faust auf klicken
sex & liebe chemie bis dann bleibt
moment moment moment alles der reihe
nach bis dann bleib dran